Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace.
Man's for wankity is such a wondrous thing.
Be high, doofs of rum, see, come take your place.
We're leaving soon for...
Here to tell the...
Yes, it is divine here.
Be much worse.
And for all, let's face it, this will never get off the ground.
Never supposed that it wouldn't you.
Come, I've had to do all this work.
Keep morale.
Don't worry about this place, we're doing all...
What about the computer?
What condition is it in?
We can play games with it.
That's about all for now.
Well, go and play a game.
It's good for the morale.
Do you suppose you can tear yourself away from your game?
Certainly not.
Are you content playing your gods?
Listen, wife.
You've got a solution.
Let's hear it now.
Oh, what's the point?
You never listen.
Hey, Mary, when the argument starts, goodbye card game.
I'm going to watch the mortals for a little while.
Want to go, Afro?
Yes, I'll go with you, Apollo, with pleasure.
I've just about had all I need to take of this.
Wobbles, they're boring.
You can say that again, Apollo.
Their domestic squabbles are boring.
Something's wrong. Let's go and look.
Problem, Sergeant.
No, same thing as always, Captain.
We shot out a couple of warning shots.
A ship with two youngsters wanted to know what was going on here.
Well, the warning shots didn't scare them off, so we fired and burned it to a cinder.
Just routine, Captain.
You couldn't have avoided it.
How could we?
We let one in here, and the next day hundreds of others will sail in.
Sir, we certainly can't permit anyone to get close to Olympus, can we?
You did the right thing. Let's go.
Captain, is it true that we're leaving soon?
Yes, Sergeant. Soon. Soon.
I think that our captain isn't telling the troops the whole truth.
He knows as well as we do we can't leave.
Trump and Trump again.
Commander, message. I received a message.
It's a ship. It's requesting the commander's authorization to land.
What do you expect me to do, idiot?
You know the transmitter's out, so just let it come.
To our planet Mytho. Glad that you came.
Wait a minute, and what are you doing here, you two?
Get out of here right now, unless you fight and stand.
That's enough, Ares. Please keep quiet, will you?
Very long while since visitors were here.
Lieutenant Piero of Omega Intergalactic Patrol
and Lieutenant Mercedes and our assistant, Metro.
Commander Jupiter of the craft Olympus are not working.
And this is my family.
First, I'll introduce my sister, Demeter.
Welcome.
My daughter, Artemis.
My sons, Hermes and Ares, the ones that argue all the time.
A wonderful family.
That isn't all of them. The others you will meet later.
We sent you a signal requesting landing authority.
Our equipment no longer functions.
Our onboard instruments indicated the presence of a heat source here.
We even detected motor being fired. We decided to come and investigate.
That was just one more unsuccessful attempt to start our engines.
They don't function at all. My son Vulcan continues trying as our chief mechanic.
And have you been here for a long time?
An eternity.
We can't take all of you on our ship, but if you'd like, we'll transmit a message for you asking for help.
Or we can send back a transport ship for you.
Yes, Lieutenant, with pleasure.
We can put it to all the others. We'll decide democratically.
You see, the truth is, some of us are quite happy to remain here, among the mortals.
The mortals?
We tend to live long lives. They don't.
There are people who are quite interesting.
Primitive, it's true, but really quite nice. They live down there.
Yeah, and they don't even know how to fight.
It reminds me of somebody, but who?
You're right. Who is it?
Come and refresh yourselves. You will visit our domain later. I am certain it will interest you both.
You got up very late this morning. I was the only one left to show you around.
We're very glad. But where are all the others?
Where they always are, watching the mortals. Don't worry, we'll locate them.
Where are they making all those offerings to you?
Why, to us, naturally. Who else?
Why don't you give them fire?
You might also teach them how to weave.
No, Jupiter is opposed to it, and especially no fire. He surely has good reason.
True, they venerate us as gods, but in turn, we help them.
Let you explore on your own, my friends. I'll come to get you later.
Doing that, we'll come back later.
My lord, this man whom I welcomed like a brother when he was in need, came into my house, but now he won't leave.
I've ordered him out, but he won't go.
It's like this, my lord. This man and I have the same father. So, what is his is mine as well.
This is my judgment. You will give him half of your lands.
But, my lord, it's not right. I don't...
Yes, my lord, I shall act according to you.
Oh, my lord! My lord, help us!
He's there again. The terrible monster's back.
He's back. The dreaded monster is here.
He's not shitting all the stuff in...
Again this nonsense?
Very well.
We'll take a look.
All of you, come along. It might be fun.
Jupiter.
Coming?
You're both well to impress the mortals.
Using it against monsters? I don't see the necessity.
Next case.
Kill this animal. It was me who killed him.
He's mine. I shot him, too.
Groucho.
Meowth.
This man is completely honest.
I know him.
His name's Peleus.
I shall support his case.
Let them share.
There's no proof who actually killed him.
True, Eris is quite right.
Yes, I agree.
I am not in accord.
Are you not? You're a coward. Defend yourself.
The fight isn't allowed between the gods.
Calm down, my brothers. Calm down.
Don't you intervene and stop the quarrel?
Is it as important as all that?
There are occasions when destiny must take its course.
Aren't you all ashamed of your behavior?
Is this an example to set? You, the gods.
Where is your sense of dignity?
And you, mortals, stop quarreling.
animal is for everyone and there will be others you friends i have good news for you pelias you
have shown yourself to be worthy the gods have chosen you for a reward that is going to please
you see that beautiful girl next case it's my turn my lord no it's my turn he's after me wait
just a moment come with me my friends and you will see something i'm sure you will find very
interesting you may have noticed one girl who's even more beautiful than the others thetis as it
happens, Jupiter is in love with her, as he is with many other girls. Naturally, this has led
to endless complications. Secretly, we've arranged for her to marry a mortal, Peleus. Peleus, you saw
a moment ago, defending his rights in Jupiter's court. Look, at all costs, don't let her see you.
Peleus is walking up. Girl of her beauty, it would be well worth watching. Go to it, Peleus!
Oh! Do you like that? This one. Pieden. He's in love with her, too. Wait, now, no doubt, I will rust.
Hold on to her and get away. Her turn. See how courageous he is, and how he wants you.
Don't you think Pileas deserves you?
And will you here and now agree to take Pileas as your husband?
As happy as I am.
Only he won't get away with it.
What am I supposed to do here?
What are my duties, Carol?
I don't know yet, Metro.
We're not too sure ourselves what we're doing.
This sort of thing.
We're as confused as you are.
But you know, all this does remind me of something.
You two?
Anyway, it's been quite a day.
Yes, and I'm pretty sure it's not over yet.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
At least you're happy for the girl, Thetis.
I would think you'd be overjoyed.
Overjoyed? And why would you think that?
It's true. You're never satisfied.
Ah! Well, it's the special guests of our little celebration.
You are courageous, a model for all the people, and we do admire all your good qualities.
But why don't you go on to help the people more than you do?
To give them our knowledge would destroy their faith in us
and their hope in a future better than their past.
They're happy like this.
I don't see how you can say that. They are hungry and cold.
cold they have never known anything better they're happy enough they're not animals they're
men my friends do what you like at home but here i decide you understand it's easy to be high and
mighty from the heights of olympus quiet wife quiet someone come fill my glass let the festivities
go on and everyone be happy my glass is empty muses come forth let the show begin it's not
right that some should go without while others live in luxury whether they like it or not will
help all the mortals to defend themselves against these gods.
And Hera, aren't you glad, poor Thetis?
I trust that her husband will survive her.
Animal is what you are, and you shall go dwell with her.
Jupiter!
That's very amusing.
No, wait!
Silence, all of you.
Here is our star attraction.
As a very special honor, you will see the latest creations of my son, Vulcan.
Here they are, women, go and get me a drink.
Yes, ma'am.
I'll give you to show everyone what you look like.
Whatever you wish.
Droids, well, well, must compare notes, but hardly worth making such a fuss.
We'll start now. Put it down there.
Just a moment.
Give all this good meat to them.
This half, they get the other half.
And the same for everything.
That's called sharing.
There we go.
That's only beginning.
We have so much to teach them, so their lives can be much richer.
How to eat and dress and how to build.
I hate to bring it up, but I would like to know what I am doing here.
An innocent question?
Patience, you'll have to wait and see.
None of us knows what surprise is waiting for us next.
Hello?
We needed animals that talk.
The closest settlement is where we're going.
There's a small formality first, I'm afraid.
You have to answer a riddle first.
Careful, if your answer's wrong, then you will die.
Well, it does kill the monotony.
Don't laugh.
What creature has first four feet, then two feet, then three feet?
paradoxically weaker the more feet it has is your answer your riddle is absolutely infantile the
answer is obvious it's man first he walks on all fours then on two feet and then when old he walks
with the help of a cane yes wait now it's my turn answer this now listen carefully now what was it
here's the question exactly what is the law of gravity there is a demonstration each planet
attracts its satellites with a force which is exactly proportional to its mass and inversely
proportional to the square of the distance separating it from the planet attracting it.
It's elementary. Now let's see what we can do to help. Let's make tiles. Sun. Man there. Hades.
They're great friends. Hades is his main supplier. Listen all of you, Vulcan will now present his
latest invention. I ask for your attention. It's our newest guard, Kalos. Let's hear it for Vulcan.
Wizzling circuits.
It's a big one.
Liven up our party.
My little sister Eris wants to try something.
Go ahead.
Well, it's just this.
It's a simple contest that our visitor award this golden apple to the woman whom he chooses
as the one who is the most beautiful of all who are here.
No, it isn't polite to our hosts.
Is this business yet?
Raw meat.
I don't care what Jupiter says.
Metro, give me a light, will you?
I want to try and cook this.
Who dared, dared give fire to the mortals?
Who?
I was disobeyed.
Thunder and lightning.
General alert.
I want the guilty one.
Vulcan.
Here is what you will do.
You will create a woman who has greater beauty than any woman ever created and name her Pandora.
To the mortals with a box of misfortune.
There can be no question of mortals being our equals.
They will start with a fire and end up with a doomsday bomb.
We're going to stay here for a long time.
Go to work and work well.
You have any idea?
Surely spotted.
We have to find another way.
Give it a try.
Start the power.
I'll join you there.
What do you say? Say, let's go.
Is this planet mytho, as old Jupiter would say, destiny take its course.
When I think that we're going to be a part of those people's mythology,
make you a giant, a colossus, eh? Titan, Prometheus, why not?
You as a goddess, pretty nice idea. Athena, for instance.
And they might construct a great city in your honor.